on Tuesday David Brooks with faux
conservative columnist for The New York
Times and a columnist so ensconced in
dry analysis of the American
upper-middle class that he seems to have
completely lost touch with reality and a
pretty condescending column aren't at
all about how upper-middle class
Americans have created their own society
versus thesis quote over the past
generation members of the
college-educated class have become
amazingly good at making sure their
children retain the privileged status
they've also become devastatingly good
at making sure the children of other
classes have limited chances to join
their ranks this is pretty astonishing
claim given the income ability in the
United States hasn't really changed
since the nineteen seventy and an income
ability in the u.s. is the same as
Europe's despite Europe's higher levels
of redistribution virtually all
differences in income mobility between
the United States and Europe are
attributable to dropping out of high
school or having babies at a wedlock but
according to Brooks the new indeed have
chopped off the ladder behind them
Brooks blames the PD accuracy stupid he
cites these facts quote upper middle
class moms have the means and the
maternity leaves to breastfeed their
babies at much higher rates than high
school educated moms and for much longer
periods upper middle-class parents have
the means to spend two to three times
more time with their preschool kids than
less affluent parents since nineteen
ninety six education expenditures among
the affluent have increased by almost
three hundred percent while education
spending among every other group is
basically flat yes it turns out that
making more money doesn't chord your
children extra benefit but that doesn't
mean that you are responsible for
shutting off someone else's path to
success
according to Brooks however the
upper-middle class is now become
exclusionary how so first Brookside
zoning laws in college admissions fair
game for talk of bending rules in favor
of the upper middle class votes
important to know that the vast majority
of high school graduates in the United
States now go to college sixty six
percent as of 2013 including forty six
percent of graduates from low-income
families but then Brooks gets weird he
goes after what he calls informal social
barriers that segregate the lower eighty
percent here is his best example quote
recently I took a friend with only a
high school degree to lunch insensitive
Lee I led her into a gourmet sandwich
shop suddenly I saw her face freeze up
as she was confronted with sandwiches
named Padrino and Pomodoro and
ingredients like sopressata
capitolium striaght o packet I quickly
asked her if she wanted to go somewhere
else and she anxiously not
yes and we ate Mexican this is idiotic
the Brooks seeks to make his friend feel
stupid did he mean to suggest that his
friend was not welcome or did he just
want to gourmet sandwich attributing
malice to people's preferences is as
nasty as excluding people through
selection of hoity-toity restaurants but
Brooks continues to feel at home and
opportunity rich areas you've got to
understand the right bar a techniques
support the right baby carrier have the
right podcast food truck tea wine in
Pilates case not to mention the right
attitudes about David Foster Wallace
child during gender norms and
intersectionality status rules are
currently about collusion about
attracting educated people to your
circle tightening the bonds between you
and erecting shields against everyone
else we in the educated class have
created barriers to mobility that are
more devastating for being invisible the
rest of America can't name them can't
understand them they just know they're
there no we have not created informal
barriers to mobility we associate with
people who think like us this is just as
true for the shishi yoga instructor
moving to Lubbock as it is for a Lubbock
kid moving to Hollywood but to pretend
in the habits of the upper middle class
in Texas are the same as the habits of
the upper middle class in Massachusetts
is stupid and ignorant Brooks's column
is just another way to suggest that
low-income Americans have insuperable
barriers to success in America and those
barriers can be found in sandwich
choices not merely the institutional
obstacles we can identify and tackle in
his column
Brooks actually contributes to a far
greater barrier to success in America
than cultural striation he contributes
to an unearned sense of victimhood when
the best option would be to encourage
people to make solid life choices rather
than lamenting their ignorance about
sopressata for the record I have no idea
what the health sopressata is because I
keep kosher so there's a cultural
barrier all to yourself I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so many things to talk about
CIE I okay so everything is insane
Donald Trump jr. has now blown up the
news cycle his release and email
exchange which we will talk about is it
illegal is it treason
so obviously Tim Kaine senator from
Virginia he's already out front saying
that this is thirties and we will
discuss whether indeed Donald Trump jr.
will be executed or whether in fact the
Democrats are going a little too far
we'll discuss the fact here they are not
great for Donald Trump jr. but we will
talk about all of that plus I have a
huge announcement coming up in about 30
seconds but first I want to say thank
you to our friends over at Birch gold so
if you're looking at the stock market
which could dive today and you're
thinking hmm I wish I had some of my
money in precious metals that's because
you're smart you should have some of
your money in precious metals I have
some of my money in precious metals it's
a great hedge against inflation against
stock market volatility against
volatility in the real estate market if
you are interested in purchasing
precious metals go to birchgold.com
slash pen birchgold.com flash pen right
now they have a comprehensive 16 page
kit reviewing how gold and silver can
protect your assets and how you can
legally move your IRA or 401k out of
stocks and bonds and into precious
metals IRA to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit go to birchgold.com
slash bend that's birchgold.com slash
been they have countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating from the Better
Business Bureau they're the people that
I trust for investment in precious
metals make sure you ask all your
questions and then go and buy some
precious metals as a hedge against all
of the vicissitudes of life
birchgold.com / Ben go and check it out
intelligent financial decision okay so
first the big announcement I promoted
this last Friday I'm not sure if I
mentioned it yesterday so on September
14th I will be going to Berkeley yay so
we'll see if an Tifa shows up young
America's Foundation and does wonderful
work sponsoring me going all over the
country they have worked out that I will
be going to Berkeley on September 14 and
I fully expect that the administration
of Berkeley will do its legal duty to
prevent the hecklers veto
okay violence from Antigua is not going
to stop us
attempted violence from Antigua is not
going to prevent this and if the Berkley
if the Berkley administration decides
they want to shut down my speech because
they can't control their own students or
outside agitators well then that's going
to be on their own head but we are
coming to Berkeley and about
well couple of months now so in
September 14th we are coming to Berkeley
I look forward to seeing everyone there
and hopefully we can have a good salad
discussion as we have a campuses all
over the country wherever they let me
speak so been at Berkeley right now
moving on Twitter hashtag been at
Berkeley looking forward to seeing you
all there on September 14th no hecklers
veto okay so on to the news well
actually you know before I mentioned the
news and I'm really like streaming this
out but before I get to the huge news of
the day I just wanna mention have you
seen this Cup this cups really great I
was told that I need to tell you about
this cover earlier in the show so here
is this beautiful magnificent cup
leftist here is hot or cold I can't
drink from it today
Jewish fast but you will enjoy drinking
from this Cup when you subscribe over at
daily we're calm I'll tell you about
that later but the cup is fantastic so
there you have it okay so the big news
of the day is of course that Donald
Trump jr. has politically pooped his
pants so this is a problem so as we
discussed yesterday there was a story
from the New York Times that said there
was a meeting between Donald Trump jr.
and Paul Manafort and Jared Kushner and
a Russian connected lawyer named Natalya
vessel Mnet's kaya which is
inappropriately Russian name and the and
I said that there were open questions
about this there's a story that came out
from The Times also a follow-on story
that says that Trump knew that she was
an agent for the Russian government
there was an email exchange containing
that information and that had not yet
been confirmed so I was a little bit
skeptical of that information until we
actually saw the emails and yesterday
the media decided that they were going
to go nuts over this in lieu of seeing
the emails they're going to suggest that
the meeting itself was criminal no
matter what there were some open
questions number one was this woman
vessel Nitz kaya actually a Russian
agent number two did Trump jr. no choose
a Russian agent number two number three
did he attempt to get information from
her about Hillary Clinton and finally
number four is that actual collusion and
number five I guess is is it illegal so
we're going to go through all of those
questions first the media and the and
the left decided immediately that this
was in fact criminal and it was
collusion John Podesta who has the most
at stake here because if he can claim
that the Russians won the election for
Trump then he looks less like a dope
because he ran Hillary's idiotic
campaign last year he says this is
starting to smell like pollution this is
yesterday before the new revelations
came out which we'll talk about in just
a second
you know it's good drip
drip drip but we keep learning more
information the story keeps changing now
it is clear that they had a specific
meeting to gather dirt on Hillary with a
Russian lawyer was close ties to the
Kremlin and you know we story again
keeps changing we never knew about that
meeting that mr. Kushner attended
earlier Donald Trump jr. said that he
was specifically went to the meeting
with the hopes of the soliciting
negative information about Hillary no
it's starting to smell more and more
like collusion - I think the public but
most importantly we really need to get
the facts straight on this okay so this
sort of drip tripping up language of
course we had to take with a grain of
salt because the Democrats have been
saying that since literally the middle
of last year and that drip drip drip
hadn't actually amounted to anything
Senator Richard Blumenthal he did the
same thing he says the meeting is
criminal we don't know what happened
this is yesterday we don't know what
happened but we know it's criminal
finally we have we're going to get the
smoking gun this will be our chance
we'll finally nail the sucker down
Richard Blumenthal from Connecticut this
meeting and most especially Donald Trump
Jr's clear acknowledgment of the reason
for it is bombshell evidence of
conspiracy and criminal intent because
he went to that meeting for a purpose
and that purpose was seeking dirt on
Hillary Clinton potentially in violation
of the law what statute would that be
and that would be 89 states code 1030
which is the Computer Fraud and Abuse
Act among other statutes there a variety
of other statute that might be covered
but an agreement to violate the law even
if somebody doesn't know all the acts is
going to be taken is a conspiracy and
the law is what you look another thing
here is not true okay the legal
provision that he just cited is really
inapplicable the idea that this was the
absolutely collusion from what we know
is that no information was actually
passed and there was no actual collusion
it was quote/unquote attempted collusion
if anything okay so we didn't even know
that as late as yesterday and then we
finally get this email exchange so the
New York Times is about to break a story
on Donald Trump Jr's emails and we're
finally going to get the full story and
that's when Donald Trump jr. makes the
genius move of revealing all of the
emails
so he reveals all of the emails himself
and they are not good so we are going to
go through them and I'm going to explain
what exactly is happening here so first
I want to introduce you to a man named
Rob Goldstone so Rob Goldstone was
apparently an agent who was involved
with one of the sponsors a Russian
families connected to the Russian
government and to Trump originally that
family was one of the co partners or
sponsors of the 2013 Miss Universe
contest over in Moscow and Rob Goldstone
was the agent for those people that's
how they got to know Trump jr. and the
Trump family I first want to introduce
you to Rob Goldstone who is the
go-between here because honestly if
you're going to have a collusion scandal
it has to be done in the most ridiculous
stupid possible light now this would be
clip 14 meet Rob Goldstone the clever
go-between in this collusion scandal
ship anything to my channel and my
favorite cops will rebel to come for
whatever one's children be careless I
shall now at the act acid etc this is
how it began
well okay the nefarious criminal
mastermind of the Nexus of Putin and
Trump we have finally discovered him
okay so Rob Goldstone contacts Donald Jr
okay this is June 3rd 2016 just days
before Trump is going to lock up the
nomination effectively and here's what
Rob Goldstone writes okay and this is
what Donald Trump jr. tweeted this out
today himself which I guess is that I
mean there's I'm just thinking of the
meme of that of that black seed going
like this right like you can't be
implicated for something bad if you
expose yourself so here's the actual
email from Rob Goldstone at this good
morning
it means just called Amina Z is the guy
who was a co investor with Trump in the
2013 Miss Universe contest it means just
called and asked me to contact you with
something very interesting the crown
prosecutor of Russia just met with his
father arrests this morning and in their
meeting offered to provide the Trump
campaign with some official documents
and information that would incriminate
Hillary and her dealings with Russia and
would be very useful to your father this
is obviously very high-level and
sensitive but as part of Russia's and
it's government support for mr. Trump
let me repeat that part of Russia's and
its government support for mr. Trump
helped along by RF and Amin what do you
think is the best way to handle this
information and would you be able to
speak to Amin about it directly I can
also send this info to your father via
rona but it is ultra sensitive so I
wanted to send to you first
best Rob Goldstone so there are a few
problems with this particular email that
again Donald Trump jr. himself released
today problem number one mate
this is openly stating that the the
meeting was based on the notion the
Russian government was going to provide
information to the Trump campaign number
two it openly says that this was going
to be part of Russia and it's government
support for mr. Trump third the email
explicitly says that if we don't go to
you then we can just go right around you
to Donald from senior right the
implication being that maybe they have
some sort of connections who Donald
Trump senior or at least could get some
connections Donald's from senior Trump
junior right back thanks Rob I
appreciate that I'm on the road at the
moment but perhaps I just speak to it
mean first seems we have some time if
it's what you say I love it especially
later in the summer like we can drop the
information later in the summer because
we do a call first thing next
when I am back best done okay so assume
for a second that Donald Trump jr. is
just a dope right okay so he's just a
dope and he doesn't know any better and
he figures okay people gather
information from all sorts of sources
all the time in fact there's a story
last year that the Ukrainian government
was meeting with surrogates of Hillary
Clinton in order to provide them
information about Trump and Russia so
the idea that foreign actors have no
influence over American elections is
just not true the daily caller Peter
Hausen reported that yesterday pointed
us at his political link where they
talked about this last year at the time
so let's assume that Don jr. is thinking
the same thing okay I'm just going to go
gather information he then goes to Manta
Ford you should know better and Jared
Kushner and all three of them meet but
they're meeting with the notion that
this is going to be some sort of Russian
government source the email exchange
continues and now Rob Goldstone writes
hides down let me know when you are free
to talk with the mean by phone about the
Tillery info you had mentioned earlier
this week so I wanted to try to schedule
a time and day best to you and your
family Rob Goldstone okay and then it
continues so there's there's more of
these email exchange like four pages of
these email exchanges and and the email
exchanges continue along these lines
they say that it mean is in Moscow I'll
call you when he gets off stage and then
finally here is the the critical email
June 7th done hope all is well this is
from Rob Goldstone it means asked that I
schedule a meeting with you and the
Russian government attorney who is
flying over from Moscow for this
Thursday I believe you are aware of the
meeting and so wondered if 3 p.m. or
later on Thursday works for you I assume
it would be at your office best Rob
Goldstone okay now the key phrase there
is the Russian government attorney so
now I need to show you tape of the
Russian government attorney okay this
Natalia vessel Nitz kaya ladies so we've
already met the go-between Andy Pandy
now we're about to meet Natasha from
Natasha and Boris she is an attorney who
clearly has links to the Russian
government but she was on NBC News
crying about how she feels betrayed and
talking about Trump jr. and says she
doesn't actually work for the Russian
government they had the impression it
appears that they were going to be told
some information that you had about the
DNC how did they get that impression
Tory they're quite possible that maybe
they were looking for such information
they want to know so badly
and this morning she denies claims she
is connected to a Russian government
effort to aid Donald Trump presidency
have you ever worked for the Russian
government do you have connections to
the Russian government yep no okay so if
you listen to vessels in the sky and
she's not related to the Russian
government but the Trump team was so
eager to get information from the
Russian government they met with her
randomly so none of this story makes any
sense from her perspective she is
clearly pretty closely linked to the
Russian government she works closely
with the Russian government has
represented state-owned businesses and a
senior government official son she is
what they call a cutout meaning that
she's somebody who has deniable links
with Russia but is pretty clearly
associated with Russia okay so what is
the upshot of all of this is it illegal
is Donald Trump's when you're going to
be executed for treason is Tim Kaine
ridiculously suggested today does it
matter
is there more to follow well talk about
all that in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Mack Weldon so Matt Weldon is
better than whatever you are wearing
right now they are the most comfortable
underwear socks shoes shirts undershirts
hoodie sweatpants when I go home I don't
dress as beautifully as I do here on the
set I get immediately into my math
welding gear in fact I'm wearing math
welds and underwear right now and they
are the greatest underwear that I own
they are just fantastic I won't even
describe to you all the ways in which
they are phenomenal I will just say that
they hold up better than any underwear
that I own you know you get like other
brands and they fall apart after you put
them in the wash 15 times that is
certainly not the case with math well
then they also have a line of silver
underwear in shirts that are naturally
antimicrobial so you don't stink as much
they want you to be comfortable
everything is very comfortable they look
good you can wear in you can work out
everything performs math Wheldon comm
it's M ACK wel do n comm math well Dan's
comm you get 20% off using promo code
Shapiro that's promo code Shapiro sha
Piro 20% off everything and it is the
best it is the best in business I mean
if you want comfortable underwear and
socks and shirts and undershirts there's
nothing better than slipping on
comfortable clothing and when you're
hanging around the house or going to go
now and Maxwell's and does it with style
again Maxwell's and calm 20% off using
promo code Shapiro that's sha PIR okay
so
is this a crime so let's assume that
everything in this email is just as it
suggests that it is and let's talk about
whether this is illegal or not so
Jonathan Turley who's a professor over
at George Washington University School
of Law he was talking about this
yesterday and the assumption which was
confirmed this morning that Trump jr.
met with the Russians knowing that they
were the Russians and that he was
attempting to get information he says
even if that's the case this is not
necessarily illegal I think he's right
here's his analysis I've been looking at
you know some of the tweets from other
former campaign operatives for other
campaigns they said you know yes we do
lots of opposition research but not with
foreign entities not with someone from
another country first of all it doesn't
appear to be true based on the Ukraine
connection that we heard about today on
the DNC side but is that true does it
complicate this legally that it was a
meeting with someone from another
country who may have a tie to the
Kremlin as most people do in some
tangental way otherwise no it's only if
we have certainly we get more
information there could be some wire
that's trip but the very the fact that
you've received information from a
foreign source is not itself any type of
crime unless you start to radically
broaden the campaign finance rules
the fact is campaigns and aides meet
with foreign leaders and Nationals all
the time they share information about
trade and other issues sometimes they
share information that that runs against
their opponent in a campaign that is
fairly routine now what is not routine
is have high-ranking people like this
meet with someone without knowing the
nature of the meeting okay what he's
saying there's exactly right it is
unusual but it's not clear there's a
criminal act if we are now going to say
that getting information from a foreign
actor is a violation of campaign finance
that that basically information counts
as some sort of donation then Hillary
Clinton was getting information
apparently from the Ukrainian government
as I mentioned earlier and so it's a
little bit difficult to make that case
so it may not be illegal but it is
certainly going to be the beginning of
the Democrats really ramping this into
high gear you thought they were rabid
now wait I mean now they're going to get
really rabid because they're going to
say okay this was just the beginning
obviously you have a willingness on the
part of the Trump campaign to meet with
members of the Russian government or
people who they felt remembers the
Russian government obviously have a
willingness on the part of the Russian
government too obvious to say straight
out that they were attempting to swing
the election for Trump now there's a way
to read that which is the Russian
government was approaching Trump in an
effort to entrap him that basically they
wanted to just mess with the election
the only way to get to Trump was to say
we support you and so they said that in
order to get drunk but really their
entire goal was to mess with the
election bottom line is that this is
going to ramp the Democratic machine
into high gear they're not going to
claim that there was an absolute
collusion however however this is not
the whole story and I'm going to talk
about what the whole story is in just a
second but for that going to have to go
over to Daily wire calm so right now if
you go over to Daly wired.com and you
subscribe for $9.99 a month we just
raised our rates you're going to get my
show the rest emotional live you're
going to get my mailbag you're going to
get Andrew Clayton's show live you're
going to get the the aptly named Michael
Knowles show is that we're naming it or
recalling it Patrol's show we don't know
yet Michael Michael Noel's show is going
to be coming as well so we're going to
be doing that we also have lots of more
goodies that are going to be coming
behind the paywall so make sure that you
go over and subscribe right now $9.99 a
month 499 dollars a year which is a
pretty hefty discount from $9.99 a month
you will get not only all of those
things plus an ad-free website you get
that with the scripted with any
subscription but you also get this
magnificent ashed hot and cold thermos
this month which is just it's the
greatest thing that you'll ever see I
mean look at this this is worth more
than your house it's unbelievable you
can see the silver shining through and
it says right on it left this tears hot
or cold the greatest way to drink what
this year's is of course in a daily wire
mug and we appreciate you joining us
over at daily wire also make sure that
if you want to listen later go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud hit subscribe make
sure that you download the show and
leave us a subscription we always
appreciate it and leave us a comment or
rather a review we always appreciate it
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
you